un bts ito est pas pour nous de
l'habitation
quand la pitance il accueilli fait mon
pour sauterie mots donnent silence la
nuit l'impreza vos caresses mots visages
mais tous aller comme un éclair il fait
noir simon paysage quand tu y arrives to
do in cilic et mariposa en compagnie
d'un pâté créole
non nous toutes et raconte l'histoire je
m'appelle axel et j'ai 14 ans je vais
vous raconter une histoire incroyable
j'essaie d'avoir ce que vous aurez du
mal à me croire mais tout ce que je vais
vous raconter est vrai alors ouvrez
grand vos yeux et vos oreilles
tu es ou saluait débat là nous a trompés
là nous les sur la lune débat boucle où
plane mais pas sur la lune
roga le ciel n'est pas noir où est
livrée allons marcher ce tir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il ya un problème un virus et une
pandémie avait secoué la pandémie cossa
mais vous n'êtes pas des scientifiques
bon ben vous êtes un peu bizarre quand
même compris ne comprend pas moins cette
cause pas français si c'est pourquoi les
habiller comment nous les bonnes
chercheurs neutre asin mais comprend pas
trop abstrait mais c'est hâtives et
suivants -
mais dérange pas ça bah c'est qu'aux
bien les gars ses oiseaux bonjour
bonjour
mais oui oiseaux la réunion ne naîtra
les oiseaux en voyant que papon des
crozes memories tech tels noms mais en
fait c'est sans doute vraiment neuf
india où nous vient planète et appelant
brocal nous cherchent d'autres racines à
ce moment là par curiosité j'ai voulu en
savoir plus sur leur histoire ne connais
pas
[Musique]
et bah tu vois devant c'est tout on a
passé des heures à échanger à discuter
même si parfois et n'a beaucoup de
chemin
au fait comment cette chapelle un croc
rolland et toi bon c'est babouk bon là
c'est pas tout mais sans menace de
chiens camarades mais fait pas autant
moins alléchant jason comme ne l'a pas
aimé cette mort menace hautement jeu
talus et la boîte bagel non aux mères
guerre ici ni moche car criant lé mot
gars ou six boucane et toi tu veux que
ma salle et à brive et à houla rappelle
vraiment bas beaucoup bienfaits du genre
oui si j'aurais fait sans nom oui la fée
sono à temps a tendance à nous at il
affirmé
cric et crac que les garçons pendant que
les caries qui écoutait musique de miel
ou lâchement de lévis et
mitraille et et tout le monde a le tout
cas atika tigana passé une super soirée
je ne les ai pas vous partir dans la
nuit ce fut comme un grand vide
voilà
rock roll à babu a beau être la barbe ou
le vaisseau et là regardez là à balanod
gay pu rentrer la case la pag rababou si
les gagnants en plus naturel nouveaux
camarades
aster allons voir lit de nuit l'impreza
vous caresse le visage mais tous aller
comme l éclipse
il fait noir simon paysage quand est
arrivé